das sind das überhaupt die für fächer
das könnt ihr mir auch mal schreiben
leute die ahnung haben die haben ja
ahnung von allem quasi und was sind das
für fächer da oben ich weiß nicht kann
man irgendwie so ein gürtel rein tun
sondern ich habe mit schwarzem gehört
kein car at
hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zurück zu einer
weiteren folge minecraft doppelklick
darauf macht und zwar der folge wo ich
gerade wenn ihr diese folge wird in
hamburg bin weil ich ja vom zweiten bis
vierten in hamburg bin vom zweiten
morgens bis vierten abends und da habe
ich mir gedacht dass ich da einfach
jetzt mal die letzten folgen weil er mit
cap aufgenommen und jetzt wollte ich
noch ein bisschen hier alleine aufnehmen
ganz einfach aus dem grund hier ist
überall an breaking nur drauf da muss
nach zolder draufpacken und mich haben
auch ganz viel darauf angesprochen luca
du brauchst eine brille
du hast da kommt anstatt an anstatt
anstatt sollte aber drauf gemacht ich
hab mal wieder ein paar
ich heiße alter die sun ladies aus aber
ich muss die ganze box gleich noch töten
weil das so blöd am klackern ist ich
habe da sehr viele leute darauf
angesprochen auch sehr viele leute
deswegen beleidigt tut mir leid so sollt
et pax eben drauf damit ich die ganze
rüstung selbstverständlich immer wieder
bekomme so jetzt sollten einige von euch
wieder in ordnung sein ach so das war da
schon von anfang an darauf dass man
nämlich auch leute dass ich die sachen
von meinen anderen sachen hier
unternehmen soll von meinen anderen
mögen beispielsweise et cetera damit ich
mehr level habe um
hier die links zu verzaubern damit ich
mir da will hat um eine rüstung zu
verzaubern
das werde ich auch denke ich machen den
legia bogen möchte ich mich noch
heftiger verzaubern
ich weiß nicht was besser ist der christ
water bogenschießen glaube ich sogar
gleich schnell
wenn ich mir diesen livia burri angucke
so und jedoch der crystal ball schneller
ja gut wahrscheinlich werde ich dann
doch ich weiß es wirklich nicht ob ich
auf den von minden liga bogen brennt man
doch oder
ich weiß nicht ich schaue mal ganz kurz
mir das bei ihnen
japan oder so der hinten irgendwo ist
weil ich weiß echt nicht das müsste die
mir echt mal schreiben welchen mob soll
ich auch nicht welchen moppel sondern
welchen bogen soll ich mitnehmen so und
warum sind wir überhaupt eigentlich gar
keine mops irgendwie da pacheco boys und
nennt also so 13
also ich wollte nur gucken ob die
brennen bleibt bestehen
die brände nicht aber das diesen
directly tot
ja ich weiß ist nicht legal bogen oder
crystal bogen welches man diese blumen
sind solche fälle so richtig heftig
legia bogen oder crystal bogen ich weiß
echt nicht wenig daneben soll schreibt
mir das mal einfach wie in ihr nehmen
würde und dann ja dieser folge dass er
noch nicht machen aber in der nächsten
folge werde ich mich danach mit den
kommentaren auseinandersetzen
ich kann ja mal kurz die ganze
verzauberung auf den crystal bogen
packen die auf dem regenbogen halt drauf
sind so als habe ich 5 50 level
da kriegt erst mal auf jeden fall power
5 an breaking drei punch was so das
war's erst mal mit dabei daniel sauter
dackel draufpacken erstmal nicht doch
geht und infiniti 22 oder soul theater
ja erstmal infiniti com das ist erstmal
wichtiger ist jetzt empfindet die drauf
ja jetzt nehme ich mir ganz der finepix
paar mal ganz kurz diese spastizität zu
töten so ich bomba level jungs sondern
noch mehr drin
nee das kann ja okay ich mache mal ganz
kurz dem opfer an ich hab jetzt wieder
acht level
ja ich weiß nämlich zurzeit echt nicht
welchen bogen ich benutzen soll soll ich
den legia bogen benutzen den ich mir so
lange gekostet habe oder doch lieber den
crystal bogen der an sich viel schneller
schießt also allemal
die hält er dennoch ich habe ganz lange
schwer da unten drin hängen
richtig komisch aus ich weiß echt nicht
was ich da sag ich mal nehmen soll
christel bogen schießt schneller aber
lee gebogen war so es war so ein langer
weg zum legia bogen und ich weiß halt
auch zwei oder manchmal drei pfeile aber
damit sein
ich meine legato bögen werde ich dann
wahrscheinlich nur auf distanz benutzen
und dann ist ja so dass ich wollte
eigentlich gar keine karte an machen und
dann ist es ja so dass der lega bogen
dass man wahrscheinlich eh nur ein pfeil
trifft von den zwei oder drei pfeilen
und dann kann ich eigentlich eher
christel bogen benutzen weil der ja dann
eigentlich grundsätzlich schneller
schießt und da jeder fall trifft so
packe ich erst mal drauf ja ich
verzauberten jetzt einfach am heftigsten
so am heftigsten wie geht kann ich da
noch irgendwas oft packen nicht okay ich
hab alle drei level
ja ich denke ich werde an den crystal
benutzt dann pack ich den liga bogen
einfach mal wieder kurz die meine kiste
ran
ich habe mir nach welt ist nicht das war
nicht ein zweites mal eine nachricht
so legt man leute ich hab ich soviel
emery charts
das ist heftig und ich brauche die
eigentlich alle nicht lassen auch noch
welche
ich werde bald irgendein livestream
machen wo ich das alles dort ihre
freunde da könnt euch darauf gefasst
machen
das wird einfach ein sortier live
trainer braucht keiner hier irgendwie
oder ich werde es nie langweiligen folge
machen und keine ahnung muss sich dann
auch keine angucken sagt ihr sterbt ihr
erstmal auf alle diese kriege ich
eigentlich so ach so ich muss immer zwei
oder drei mal schlagen damit die alle
tot sind auch immer was los drin das ist
auch heftig
15 level das geht nicht so schnell von
euch nur drei so gut
christel bogen noch ein bisschen was
kommt da noch drauf auch erstmals sollte
deshalb nur noch vier levels kann er
wird wieder nichts draufpacken
aber warte ich kann ja schon mal ganz
kurz gucken hat ja schon mal ca hat er
an breaking drauf an breaking drei
empfindet die einst in panik reden heißt
weil das sind die wichtigsten sachen an
breaking bad findet die beiden burgen
würde ich grob sagen dass du das ist
aber auch ganz wichtig und so waren die
show gebucht da an den test erst mal
ganz kurz
ja der liga bogen macht mehr schaden das
ist so aber den hier kann ich
letztendlich ganz oft kämen
von daher ist es letztendlich doch sogar
besser selbst wenn ich dann gegner sehr
direkt rot schade
man kann entweder man ja nicht mit mit
links treffen mit mit pfeilen ich dachte
mit dem christa botschaft dass wenn er
so richtig schnell schießt eigentlich
schon drauf dabei dieser boss oder alle
hier
da hab ich mir schon die sachen genommen
ich war glaube ich schon drin
ich möchte jetzt ein paar gegner dass
ich hier so ein bisschen wieder action
wasserbecher für ein neues bescheid
schon sein gegner war man aber den kann
ich echt geil spam
ja ich glaube das ganz gut ja ich glaube
dass nach diesem flug wieder drin
topolánek kordon er ich brauche ein paar
gegner parkplatz ich habe es irgendwie
bock auf kriegt wenn jetzt einer drauf
kommt würde ich glaube ich wird den
angreifen jetzt kommt seiner drauf steht
eindeutig treffer nicht das liegt aber
an diesen doofen stelle ich packte mal
ganz kurz raus und versucht dann hier so
ein bisschen 'schon uns besser läuft es
läuft also gar nicht mal besser ich
glaube michael oft überflüssige bei mir
irgendwie doch jetzt weiß ich okay dass
ich schau mal wo sie noch ein paar mops
und so ein bisschen rum punch nassen
pinguin psa psa mir sonst das alles rum
laufen keine ahnung wir sind einfach
gegen den tierschutz waren wir töten
einfach alles was rum läuft noch einmal
gar keine mops mehr hier was das da oben
was ist das
oha sagt nicht hier ist ein dings
abgestürzt doch tatsache dass allerdings
abgestürzt da ist tatsächlich irgendwo
uns hat es geknallt hier recht jemanden
blogge ich weiß nicht ist silvester
welches ihr aufnehmen ich produziere vor
hey du pc dahin pizza stirb wir haben
genug hier sind schüler acht minuten
hier so ich wollte nämlich mir einen sky
team blog machen und dafür brauche ich
obsidian deswegen fliege ich jetzt sagt
da hinten weil ich obsidian benötige
weil ich das hier machen möchte habe ich
sehr viele leute geschrieben luca das
ist kein linksblock das ist nämlich ein
skype im blog der sich nach oben links
und 20
dann habe ich dafür braucht obsidian ich
lese ja immer fleißig eure kommentare wo
war denn dieser vorstellen bei denen ich
hier irgendwo das team davon bei euch
jetzt einfach etwas ab obwohl es da oben
nicht irgend was drin ist es nicht in so
einem falle
ach komm ich wollte einfach ein bisschen
was ab davon
währenddessen kann ich ein bisschen
darüber quatschen was was ist denn das
da hinten dann was sich sonst noch so
viele pläne hat und zwar hatte ich mir
für diese folge aufgeschrieben dass code
touch runterzunehmen dafür sollte da
drauf zu packen und dieses team blog
fertig zu kriegen dass wir für diese
folge thema ich brauchte gar nicht
schreiben für die nächste folge menschen
für die nächsten meine haare sind mega
normal
in der aufnahme mit cap übrigens hatte
ich gerade geduscht deswegen weil meine
haare da so zerzaust die sind immer
zerzaust aber damals noch heftiger aus
als sonst und nochmal eine starke
aufforderung an euch wieso kommt die
lava darum nicht runter sonst halt da
oben bleiben das ihr mir schreiben
sollte was ihr genau von der qualität
jetzt ihr haltet weil ich find die
qualität persönlich viel besser weil
meine stimme quasi gleichmäßig auf einem
level ist guck mal hier übrigens einige
meinten allerdings dass ich mehr halle
ich weiß nicht woran das liegt das dass
da einige meinen aber
eigentlich sollte ich gerade wenige
hallen deswegen habe ich mir dieses ding
mehr oder weniger gekauft beziehen sich
auf wenn ich deswegen gekauft sondern
weil die stimme gleichmäßig auf einem
level ist egal ob ich jetzt relativ
leise jährige oder relativ laut die
stimme sollte ca und da sehe ich auch
hier rechts in der haut lässt die spur
dass die stimme auf einen level ist und
das ist quasi genau das was ich mir mit
diesem kauf beziehen wir
weihnachtswunsch machen wollte ich
wollte auch noch gucken wie kann ich mir
denn jetzt eigentlich ein schwert auf
den friedensvertrag den halt nicht immer
noch dabei wenn ich jetzt ein schwert
habe es ist jetzt auf meinem rücken
näher die spitzhacke ist auf meinem
rücken wie komisch wenn ich mir das
schwert aufrücken packen so ich weil ich
mach einfach immer so
nee nee nee was sind das überhaupt die
für fächer das könnte mir auch mal
schreiben leute die ahnung haben die
haben mir ahnung von allem quasi und was
sind das für fächer da oben ich weiß
nicht kann man irgendwie so ein gürtel
rein tun sondern ich habe mich schwarzen
gehört keinen charakter car at hanuta
und duplo schreibt mir einfach was das
ist ich bin irgendwo runtergegangen
na gut das ist das achte obsidian das
heißt man -star blake ist ich habe sogar
ob ich jetzt ab nach hause und dann geht
eigentlich hiervon die rüstung auch
kaputt wenn ich einfach so laufen
eigentlich eigentlich nicht oder aber
eigentlich ich nutze diese obwohl
eigentlich wenig nachsicht habe nutze
ich auch die fähigkeiten der rüstung aus
von daher dürfte die eigentlich nicht
kaputt gehen
und ja irgendwie wohnt ja auch relativ
scheiße weil hier ist komplett frei
da könnte ich ja eigentlich hinziehen so
ein fettes grundstück mit garten dann ja
ich glaube dass sich hin
wie geil dass wir dann setze ich den weg
dann noch ein bisschen um dann macht das
in der nächsten folge dann setze ich den
weg hier ein bisschen um
ich hoffe dass krieg so hin wie ich mir
das vorstelle ich werde nämlich auch
hören geräusche ein bisschen oder
paranoia und zwar ok ich muss ich auch
noch irgendwie mitkriegen mit dem bau
gebäude auch nicht würde ich dann den
weg einfach ein bisschen anders machen
um ist hier denn na gut mir soll es
recht sein ich brauche die sachen
bleiben alles unnötig hier wieder so
nein da bleibst du jetzt
da muss ja nicht wirklich noch ein blog
darunter setzen oder habe ich noch
irgendein blog den ich jetzt nicht
brauchen oder wie heißt noch mal dieser
nachbar den dinkelberg das sage ich
jetzt immer noch steine
ich hasse das auch dass ich immer mit
einem vollen inventar rumlaufe irgendwie
kann ich das gar nicht obwohl ich hier
kannst eigentlich sogar so bleiben der
weg hat hier nur ein bisschen kürzer
muss da ein bisschen gerade hin packen
als ich den bogen wieder aufgesammelt ja
da sammle ich jetzt einfach mal hinterm
haus ein tenor ins haus von der hec
relativ egal da wird auch schon gekriegt
so damit dass gm ein neues grundstück
dessen dass zwischen damit dass eine
scheiße drin
ach die kann man auch kostenlos
verzaubern habe man das neue café was
das hier das war mal glaube ich die
wahlurne oder das 69 kohle darin mit die
nehme ich mit also nicht wenn das gehört
also da kommt dann meinen mein holzleim
hin
so und jetzt seid ihr mal wieder ein
bisschen scheiße
[ __ ] verdammt
zum glück ist mir das noch aufgefallen
dass da noch die monster fall ist oha
das du dir wenigen ohren alter ist es
heftig das ist gerade krass das ist
einfach nur xp tour um mein gott und ich
sehe dass wieder so verzauberte heftige
mops und sich zwischen das jetzt wieder
eine rolle was hab ich den jetzigen
sammelt man jetzt schon tun
ich gehe dahin und krieg schaden
ich weiß nicht ob ich nicht richtig
hunger fressen das schon erschießt mich
da wir ab wie pizza als ihr kapital
einfach so hier so erschrecken
du kommst da rein das ist jetzt mein
ziel im abfall vernünftig machen
scheiße wie lange der auch braucht das
alles hier fertig zu machen so die
ganzen show coupe diaz hier flint
dringen so ein fall brauche ich dann
noch den bogen nicht eben freundlich
räumlich die rückseite brauche ich auch
anders meist außer den rucksack da rein
denn wer so witzig so dich brauche ich
nicht brauche ich nicht stolz labs war
nicht so
eigentlich war nicht alles voll okay
meine lieben freunde ja darin nahm putz
holz holz holz das nur noch einer
aber dass ein heftiger
jetzt kommt die ganze scheiße da rein
rechnerisch estate die partie malereien
vielleicht kann die anlage brauchen die
liegt er sogar noch nicht drin ich weiß
gar nicht korrekt nun als sachen aber
ich damals so fanatisch von von diesem
schwert aus sodass weil ich unbedingt
haben
das ist ja relativ klein diamond spot
packe ich auch mal hier rein und die sky
und op die habe ich auch noch hier und
zwar mögen ja gut ich den restlichen
sagt manchmal ich wollte meinen bogen
und mein schwert muss noch verzaubern
mein schwert da muss mich auch noch was
drauf feier sp weiß gar nicht viel das
bringt fox wollte ich auf jeden fall
drauf packen
mutig wäre vielleicht auch ganz
interessant hab ich wieder nur noch fünf
level aber da sind jetzt relativ viele
sachen drauf das ist megageil
diese schwäche ich dann aber
wahrscheinlich muss man den schalter
wieder einpacken sonst sieht das ja
alles betrieb auf dem bogen komme ich
hab den bogen relativ viele sachen und
das ändert spot und die komplette
rüstung auf sollte aber die rüstung muss
nach auf ich mache jetzt mal wieder an
und dann sortiere ich jetzt glatt immer
ganz kurz ein bisschen diese diese dinge
das regt mich auch so oft das ist
einfach mitten im weg stehe ich musste
meine ganze ding sortieren so ein
bisschen aber bald umziehen ist es auch
relativ egal so dann brauch ich das ja
auch mal ab ob die geschäftsbücher diese
bücherregale die sagen so schön aus weil
ich einfach auch nur gemacht weil ich
sie dann halt hatte ach so ich wollte
auch noch zu seinen star wie ein block
machen dann setze ich den startblock da
nämlich schon mal hin so und da kommt er
rein dann habe ich ein star dem blog der
skyteam blogger ist das scalping
niedriger sagt dass darwin blog
willst dich nicht aktivieren sollte es
nicht doch besser da dietrich ihnen
achtung luca geht ins internet sky dem
blog exit so moment des calvin brock ist
decorative blog simulierte blogger dies
käme das navigieren die skybar wir sind
da sind niederfischbach und klaus sowie
im redstone sinken sie skypen heute das
special bieten auch der brauch ein ach
so etwas natürlich dann sinnvoll wenn da
was braucht habe ich überhaupt ich
glaube ich hab gar kein redstone oder
ich wollte ja nie wissen
ich wollte auch nie redstone haben
irgendwie so stix irgendwo
ok 16 fackeln landes bräuchte er nicht
wenn ich noch existenzen finde macht mir
die trivial aber noch fertig da also der
braucht das die ganze zeit dann packe
ich dass ein fahrrad und ausgeklügelter
besser die zeit seine so in der nächsten
folge pack stadt dann schiltern als ich
nämlich nix folge direkt jetzt auch ihr
braucht euch dann nicht gedanken machen
dass ich irgendwie dann so die nächste
folge ein paar wochen aufnehmen und dann
sage warum hat ihn in einer abgebaut und
sollen ein verbrechen gewünscht also der
sieht auf jeden fall hat es ist der
erste ski im block in unserer stadt wo
mein gott kommen die stadt oder hinter
das ist alles dahinter so beleuchtet
dass die heftig geil aus irgendwie weiß
ich mir gefällt dieser sky blockieren
wie ich mag den der es der school
das sieht doch irgendwie cool aus wenn
man das so sieht aus wie so die
nordlichter nordlicht egal freuen wenn
es euch gefallen hat will ich mich über
eine positive bewertung freunde des
ansehens zunächst wieder macht's gut
einen guten rutsch ins neue jahr hattet
ihr hoffentlich weil die folge kommt er
am dritten raus ja am dritten